[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a death penalty attorney appointed to
laurie valo de bell
is this a sign the so-called doomsday
mom could face the highest penalty
in the murders of her two children and a
husband charged with killing his wife do
whatever it takes to bring you back
the evidence the prosecutors say they
have against barry morphy
plus jury selection begins in r kelly's
trial defense attorneys now requesting
charges be dismissed
including allegations the singer gave
herpes to a teenage girl
and a grieving widow her daddy is a hero
a sheriff's deputy killed on duty the
jury now must decide
if his convicted killer should face the
death penalty law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
another major update with the doomsday
couple chad and laurie dabo
but first to colorado where an affair a
spy pen
and countless searches are being
presented as evidence
against barry morphy the man accused of
killing his wife law and crime's angina
levy is here with details on the case
brian suzanne morpheu went missing on
mother's day in 2020. her body has never
been
found prosecutors are laying out why
they believe her husband barry
killed her oh suzanne if anyone is out
there i can hear this
that has you please
we'll do whatever it takes to bring you
back that was barry morphy
last year pleading for the safe return
of his wife suzanne
her bike was found on a trail where she
rode and her helmet found less than a
mile away without any damage
on the first day of the preliminary
hearing a detective testified suzanne
morphew bought a spy pen
because she thought barry was having an
affair the detective said suzanne was
having a two-year-long affair with a man
named jeff
in may of this year prosecutors in
chaffey county colorado
charged morpheu with murder after
deliberation tampering with physical
evidence
and attempting to influence a public
servant suzanne's body has never been
found
forensic death investigator joseph scott
morgan has followed the case
there's no corpus delecti if you will
there's no nothing forensically in that
sense to hang your hat on you know what
we would be
looking for it remember he's charged
with first-degree homicide here
so they must have some pretty
substantial evidence to still
be holding on to him that they would
charge him with
essentially the highest count that you
can in this category
sheriff's deputies fbi agents and others
have searched for suzanne
and one investigator testified during
the hearing searching around her home is
still a work in progress
a reporter in the courtroom says
morphy's daughters attended the hearing
sitting behind him to support him
despite prosecutors calling him a
murderer we love you
we miss you
now there was no evidence according to
the detectives
that barry morphy was actually having an
affair there was also testimony that the
dvr from the home was missing so there
was no surveillance video from the day
that suzanne morphy went missing or the
day prior
this hearing is a preliminary hearing so
it's expected to last about four days
at the end the judge will determine
whether or not there is enough evidence
to take the case to trial brian
thanks angenet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman
and terry austin julie suzanne
was having an affair recording some
information with a man named jeff so can
we expect the defense to point to him as
the
an alternative suspect sure i mean keep
in mind that
now we have a case where there is no
body recovered so i think the first
thing that the defense is going to do is
say
no body no proof that she is in fact
dead
the second thing is well if they believe
that there's enough evidence to
establish
that she's dead well who killed her did
she take her own life
or is it the person that she was having
an affair with all these years that's a
potential suspect
again we don't know much because some of
it is still sealed
but i think it'll be very interesting to
see what if any evidence
comes out that establishes without
question that the husband is the person
that committed this crime
versus anybody else now terry as we
begin through this case what facts
is the prosecution bringing out that
make you think this case will be
put on for trial well you know brian so
far they are holding the facts
close to the vest but we do know that
there were 135
search warrants that were issued and
they spoke to over
400 people that's a lot of interviews
and three terabytes
of information so there's a lot of
information out there
and i think we know that this is first
degree murder and first degree murder in
colorado
is defined as deliberate and
premeditated so
we're going to have to have evidence of
some premeditation here
and i think it'll be a lot of forensic
evidence maybe some computer searches
so we'll see what happens here
absolutely and janet was there testimony
about barry morifu's truck
during the hearing yes brian there was
one of the detectives testified about a
tracking device of sorts
that was on barry morphy's truck and
they said that basically
that tracking information showed that
from 2 47
on saturday may 9th until 5 37 a.m
the next morning on mother's day that he
took
steps to get rid of evidence to
cover up the death and disappearance of
suzanne morphew
and they talked about how he basically
said he left around for work at a
certain time
but it didn't jibe with what that report
was showing all right so i guess that's
how they're trying to prove this case in
the preliminary here we'll make sure to
give you updates as it continues thank
you everyone
now to our other top story so-called
doomsday mom lori valodebel
has been appointed a death penalty
certified attorney
laurie valodebel along with her husband
chad debell are charged with the murders
of lori's two children
j.j valo and tyler ryan last week
prosecutors announced their intent to
seek the death penalty against chad
if convicted laura's case is on pause
for now while she's deemed incompetent
to stand trial
but court records show attorney jim
archibald is now appointed to her case
alongside attorney mark means according
to east idaho news archibald is one of
the few qualified death penalty
certified attorneys
in eastern idaho terry now that the
prosecution is seeking the death penalty
against chad davao
is this new attorney a smart way for
lori to cover herself
it's not only a smart way i think it's
going to be something she's going to
need and i think mark means is going to
need it
we know that jim archibald is a very
seasoned attorney as far as the death
penalty is concerned
mark means is a personal injury lawyer
and he's a family lawyer he doesn't
really have
the expertise needed for this type of
case if in fact
laurie is charged with the death penalty
so
we'll see what happens but i do think
it's going to help her overall at the
end of the day
now julie the last high-profile case and
he's had a few uh that jim archibald
handled was brian drips
and he got him 20 years to life could
this be a positive appointment for lori
then
so it depends on how you look at it
there's an argument to be made that
his client was found guilty and
therefore it's not a great
great person to bring on because he was
not able to convince the jury that his
client was not guilty of a crime
on the other hand remember this the
issue and that we seem to think is that
he's being brought on
because this is a potential death
penalty case and the fact that he was
able to avoid the death penalty in this
other case
does speak volumes about his ability to
be able to convince a jury
if in fact she is found guilty and if in
fact they are seeking the death penalty
with regards to this specific defendant
yeah and that brian dribs case was
heinous in of itself so
perhaps this case being equally as
heinous maybe a little bit more
may help the the lorry velodebel in
convincing a jury that death felony
should not be on the table but i think
that is a tall order but of course we'll
keep an
update on the idaho v lori valo day bell
case as well as her husband chad davao
thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily what
a sheriff is saying about the
investigation
into new york's governor andrew cuomo
but first jury selection in r kelly's
trial
his defense has motioned to dismiss
charges before testimony begins
the shocking allegations ahead
welcome back jury selection is now
underway for r kelly's trial in new york
but the disgraced singer's attorneys are
asking a judge again to dismiss charges
against him
including knowingly transmitting herpes
r kelly appeared in federal court on
monday as his trial for racketeering and
sex trafficking charges begins
but before court began his attorneys
filed a motion to dismiss charges in his
criminal indictment
defense attorneys say that transmitting
herpes does not fall under public health
law
and those charges against him are a
clear mischaracterization
and interpretation of the application of
the statute
in a recent pre-trial motion prosecutors
allege r kelly met a 15-year-old girl in
florida
filmed himself having sex with her and
produce child pornography
prosecutors say quote as a result of the
defendant's actions
jane doe number five contracted an
incurable sexually transmitted disease
at the age of 17. our kelly's accused of
abusing women and girls over two decades
12 jurors and six alternates won't be
selected the trial is expected to last
six weeks
back with us as criminal defense
attorney julie reynoldman and terry
austin
terry with 20 or so jane does two john
does in a long
long list of sexual and racketeering
charges what kind of jury do you think
the prosecution is looking for in this
case
you know i think the prosecution is
going to have to look for a jury
who hasn't been the subject of any sort
of criminal activity
particularly as relates to sexual
assault and that might not be easy
because there might be family members
there might be friends who
are subject to that so they're going to
have to go through a lot of jurors as
far as that's concerned
they're also going to want jurors who
won't be enamored with a grammy
award-winning artist
like r kelly so it has to be someone who
maybe doesn't know his music as much or
won't be impressed
and finally i think they're going to
need yours who can understand
the nuances behind the racketeering
charge because that's an important
charge as well
now so now julie how do you think the
court will handle the motion to dismiss
charges involving transmitting
herpes to teenagers so the law isn't
completely
clear in terms of whether or not herpes
is in fact an std i think
the bigger issue brian is a i think this
is the least
of r kelly's concerns i mean these are
misdemeanor charges
and even if those cases were were
dismissed in some way the judge will
likely
let in the evidence anyway because it
establishes
a sexual relationship with the with the
young woman and so at the
i don't think it matters and if he's
convicted
the misdemeanors are going to be
absolutely irrelevant anyway so
again i don't know what the jury's the
judge's final decision is
i think he is going to keep those um
charges in place
but i don't think it makes any
difference yeah either
stylistically if you want to call it
that way the jury's going to hear about
it and not be too happy
about sexually transmitted diseases or
infections or just factually they'll
come in as a charge so it's kind of
you're down if you do them to you don't
we'll we'll see how that plays out
thank you both turning now to more top
legal news the trial of robert durst has
resumed afterwards abruptly halted
due to a member of the public in the
courthouse testing positive for coven
19.
the real estate air is accused of
murdering his best friend susan berman
in december 2000.
prosecutors have rested their case and
the defense's first witness is on the
stand
memory expert dr elizabeth loftus faces
day three of cross-examination
once her testimony concludes durst is
expected to take the stand in his own
defense
be sure to tune in to law and crime
network for gavital gavel coverage
coming up on law and crime daily will a
jury recommend life in prison or the
death penalty for a convicted cop killer
plus what criminal charges are being
considered against new york's governor's
andrew cuomo
one of his accusers speaking out next
we're back calls are growing for new
york's governor andrew cuomo to resign
and the local sheriff is now saying
cuomo could possibly face misdemeanor
charges
the woman known as executive assistant
number one is speaking out after filing
the first criminal complaint against
cuomo
she told cbs news the governor groped
her twice first won new year's eve 2019
while taking this selfie the second time
in november 2020
came back to me and that's when he put
his hand up my blouse
and cupped my breast over my bra i
exactly remember looking down
seeing his hand which is a large hand
thinking to myself oh my god
this is happening cuomo is denying
allegations and his attorneys say
she's not telling the truth the governor
has repeatedly denied that ever
took place and quite frankly
when she first raised this in early
march
he was stunned but over the weekend the
albany county sheriff said
a criminal investigation is underway
based on again i'm
really on the peripherals of this but it
would probably be a misdemeanor
possibly a couple here to break down the
allegations against new york governor
cuomo
is criminal defense attorney julie
rendelman and co-host terry austin
terry executive assistant juan or
brittany comiso has come out to say that
the governor is a liar and spelled out
why your reactions to her breaking her
silence
you know we have seen in the past that
there are a multitude of witnesses
that don't come out and don't say
anything for a while when they are
victims to
these types of assaults and here i think
one of the
issues might have been fear of
retaliation and so
when she came out she decided to do this
once she
saw cuomo in a press conference she
actually said
that she was offended that he looked
quite arrogant while he was doing this
and that she thought he was speaking
directly to her so
i think she hesitated it first because
she feared this retaliation in the
workplace
but then ultimately she got a courage
after she saw him
denying basically everything that people
have been saying about him
including absolutely now julie the
allegations
sound like misdemeanor forcible touching
or sexual abuse in the third degree
as a former prosecutor how does a da's
office handle such a serious case with
relatively low jail time
keep in mind you know that a report was
rendered and
the da's office isn't going to just rely
on that report if they're doing their
due diligence which they need to
they should be doing it in every case
but particularly a case where the stakes
are so high
um and so i think what they're going to
be doing is they're going to be crossing
their tees dotting their
their eyes making sure that there's
nothing about the complainant
that would render questions about her
credibility
because the last thing they want to do
is go forward with these allegations go
forward with an arrest
and find out there's something either in
the complainant's history
or some motive that would have been
ulterior to just
simply wanting to come forward against
uh cuomo
and so i think they have a big job to do
they have limited time obviously
because of the statute of limitations
but i wouldn't be surprised if charges
come this way
yeah uh julie you have any kind of
inclination as to when we should expect
charges uh
weeks months what do you think i don't
know but
i will tell you that you know it's not
just the da's office that's handling
this specific case they need to speak to
every da's office with every complaint
because they want to understand fully
the evidence against him
in each state because that enables them
to make the best decisions in regards to
the case they have before them
absolutely it makes sense we'll see how
that investigation goes because like you
said the statute of limitations
is there i think it's two years in an a
misdemeanor in new york thank you both
when we come back will stephen wiggins
get the death penalty the latest
in the sentencing phase of a cop killer
and what awaits him on the other side of
the break
[Music]
welcome back a tennessee jury must now
decide if a man convicted of murdering a
deputy sergeant
deserves a death penalty after a little
more than an hour of deliberations
the jury found stephen wiggins guilty of
all counts including first-degree murder
vehicular arson
and abuse of a corpse wiggins shot
sergeant daniel baker in the head in may
2018
and lit baker's body on fire in his own
patrol vehicle baker's widow gave a
heart-wrenching victim impact statement
calling for wiggins to face the highest
penalty
he worked hard every day to be the best
husband father
leader and human that he possibly could
he helped many strangers and never
expected anything in return
he tried to promote good and always lead
by example
i have begged many times for god to let
me trade places with him
not because i wish to die but because
daniel deserves to live
meredith our baby girl
our precious little girl that has been
forced to grow up without her daddy she
knows that he lives in heaven
but doesn't quite understand that he is
never coming back
that he will never be here to hold her
to kiss her to watch her grow
to offer fatherly advice to walk her
down the aisle
to meet his grandchildren to do any of
the things that a father would
could and or should be here to do
all that remains are the pictures a few
videos
and many stories of the great man that i
know
undoubtedly would have given her the
world
the defense says their client deserves
mercy bringing up an instance when wigan
saved the life of a co-worker
or the fact that stephen has helped
others in his life
how you will hear in this case that he
actually saved the life of a coworker
that may be relevant to you but it might
not be relevant to another drawer
and you could give that the weight of
life but you have to remember this is an
accounting exercise this isn't you just
count up all of these mitigating
circumstances there's no magic number
you have to reach
a single mitigating factor a single
piece of mitigating evidence
could be the reason that you and your
individual moral judgment decides
to give that circumstance the weight of
life
you have to decide whether that
mitigating evidence is going to be
sufficient or appropriate
to grant mercy
julie i hear what the defense is doing
and i understand don't need a magic
number just a single
issue do you think that this jury that
found wiggins guilty so quickly though
will also sentence him to death so the
one difference is
is that the defense didn't really put on
a defense
in the trial part of this case um
they're putting on a defense now they've
saved all their arguments for the
mitigation phase
and so they hope that it's going to take
the jury much longer than an
hour to make a decision of such an
incredibly important thing
and you know look it only takes one i
think the jury you know
politics aside about feelings about the
death penalty
is going to be hard-pressed to find the
mitigation that the defense is looking
for considering the heinous
nature of this crime the fact that he
had committed other violent crimes in
the past
obviously time will tell but i think
it's going to take the jury a little
longer than an hour this time
absolutely on one hand you have the
heinousness of this crime
uh who was committed to and how it was
done on the other
it's one thing to say that you support
the death penalty but to be the actual
person to vote on it
is hard for a lot of people so of course
we got to keep our eye on this one
terry during or sorry oftentimes during
sentencing
we think the judge has already made up
their mind here the jury is deciding
so do you think the evidence so far is
swaying them
you know it's very difficult to make
this decision and for a jury to come
there have to be 12 of them to make this
decision so
it's a very personal decision i agree
with julie i think it's going to be hard
this was a heinous heinous crime
but the medical evidence so far that
we've seen in this penalty phase
has not been very strong so i do think
we might see the death penalty
having said that defense counsel did a
great job when he was arguing in his
statement
and i think the jury listened to what he
had to say absolutely the defense
attorney didn't have much but he seems
to use it as best as possible
thank you both for joining me and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you